iskandarin's gravediggers must work
quickly
the noise from the heavy machinery
disturbs what is normally a peaceful
place
with her surviving family for the bodies
of one of her sons his wife and their
three children they killed my son
because they didn't send a crane to do
the rescue did my son have nothing to
give this state didn't he serve them he
was the best mathematics teacher in hate
how could their conscience accept this
after all of his service while survivors
contend and Pray by the freshly dug
Graves of their loved ones not all of
the Dead have been identified
so they're buried here
it's respectfully done but there's
little ceremony and no mourners and
sometimes not much left to bury
the victim is now a number DNA samples
have been taken if anyone comes looking
in the future
only the dad who've been identified
accounted in the official death toll
some estimates are that the identity of
around half those killed in Monday's
earthquakes is unknown
the manager here at the cemetery tells
us these plots all the way up to the
fence would take about four years to be
filled up
it'll be full here now in three to four
days
from the distraught survivors a
complaint we've heard regularly this
past week that the government's rescue
effort has been too slow
you are tyrants you have no conscience
you took my five kids how could you let
a whole family disappear because of a
crane they are still under the rubble
for seven days now even if they got
wounded by the Quake they are already
dead now you killed them turkey's
president has admitted failings in the
initial response to the earthquake regip
type erdogan says the rebuilding will
start within weeks
the frustration here is why did those
buildings collapse in the first place
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera iskandarin